este vídeo ha sido posible gracias atrás
link las link es una herramienta de
seguridad todo-en-uno que te permite
generar contraseñas seguras almacenar
las guardar tu información personal y de
pago y guardar notas de forma segura
proteger tu privacidad y todo ello de
forma rápida y precisa beatas link.com
visual polítiques y descárgate lo de
forma completamente gratuita además
usando el código de descuento visual
polítiques podrás disfrutar de la
versión premium durante 30 días de forma
totalmente gratuita y si además quieres
seguir con ella tendrás nada menos que
un 10% de descuento y ahora vamos con el
vídeo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale
mirarlo en la wikipedia a cuantos
inmigrantes ha deportado donald trump
pensadlo bien desde la campaña electoral
trump nos ha dejado claro que no le
gustan los inmigrantes y que va a ser
inflexible con ellos y no va a dejar
pasar a ningún mexicano de forma ilegal
verdad pues atentos a la gráfica
[Música]
si os fijáis veréis que en lo que a
deportaciones respecta obama supera con
creces los números de trump significa
esto que en el fondo a trump le gustan
los inmigrantes y que se merece un
premio nobel de la paz por supuesto que
no hay muchísimos detalles que podríamos
discutir en esta gráfica pero os la he
puesto porque hay una cosa que quiero
dejar muy clara cuando hablamos de
inmigración una cosa son los hechos y
otra muy distinta a las palabras y ahora
mismo los hechos son los siguientes
los inmigrantes en la frontera sur
llegan a los 100.000 por segundo mes
consecutivo exacto en estos momentos el
continente americano vive una de las
mayores crisis de refugiados de su
historia cientos de miles de personas
están cruzando todo el territorio
mexicano para llegar a los eeuu muchos
de ellos son niños que hacen todo el
camino a pie y que llegan en condiciones
de malnutrición
[Música]
y si habéis oído bien he dicho que
cruzan el territorio mexicano porque la
mayor parte de estos inmigrantes o
refugiados no viene de méxico sino de
centroamérica en los últimos años países
como honduras el salvador guatemala se
han convertido en auténticos infierno de
violencia narcotráfico y pobreza extrema
y os preguntaréis cómo ha respondido
canal trampa a este nuevo desafío pues
con esto
donald trump a amenazar a méxico con
aranceles del 5% por la inmigración
ilegal habéis oído bien
donald trump quiere pasarle la patata
caliente a mexico que sean los mexicanos
quienes se hagan cargo de todos esos
inmigrantes que cruzan su país pero hay
una pregunta de la que no se suele
hablar que piensa el gobierno de mexico
al respecto pues bien el actual
presidente de mexico es este señor que
veis aquí que se llama andrés manuel
lópez obrador más conocido por sus
siglas hablo amlo es un político muy
izquierdas que como os podéis imaginar
no tiene ningún tipo de simpatía por
donald trump durante la campaña
electoral prometió que daría un trato
humanitario a todos los inmigrantes que
pasaran por su país pero por otro lado
méxico tendría mucho que perder si su
vecino del norte impusiera nuevos
aranceles así que al pobre de amlo no le
ha quedado más remedio que mandar al
ejército para frenar a todos esos
inmigrantes centroamericanos
esta es la narrativa que han comprado
casi todos los medios de comunicación el
malvado donald trump ha obligado a los
pobrecitos mexicanos
a maltratar a los inmigrantes para no
tener que hacerlo él misma pero de
verdad es tan simple
[Música]
por ejemplo yo tengo una pregunta si
eeuu no quiere los inmigrantes
centroamericanos porque no se pueden
quedar en mexico no sería la primera vez
que se hace un acuerdo de estas
características ahí tenemos a angela
merkel y nuestro querido amigo erdogán
en turquía pero vamos a ir un poquito
más allá cuál es la política de
inmigración de méxico pues atentos
porque os voy a dar unas cifras que os
van a hacer mucha mucha gracia en eeuu
el 14 por ciento de la población son
inmigrantes la media de la ocde está en
torno al 13 por ciento pues bien cuál
diríais que es el porcentaje en mexico
[Música]
1 % habéis oído bien si hay un país
estricto con los inmigrantes
ese es méxico pero cómo funciona
exactamente su política migratoria que
está haciendo méxico para responder a
los inmigrantes y a los refugiados que
llegan de centroamérica de verdad se
puede hablar de buenos y malos en esta
historia de verdad amlo está actuando
bajo las órdenes de donald trump o tal
vez hay algo más hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
la caravana migrante ya se lo que estáis
pensando porque es ahora cuando vienen
tantos inmigrantes centroamericanos
seamos honestos tanto honduras como
guatemala como el salvador nunca han
sido países especialmente prósperos pero
si algo nos enseña la historia es que si
algo va mal siempre puede ir a peor
entre el año 2010 y 2012 las cifras de
criminalidad se dispararon en toda esta
zona en 2009 honduras sufrió un golpe de
estado y el salvador- ha tenido que
hacer frente a las maras que son bandas
callejeras ultra violentas algo similar
ocurre en guatemala
[Música]
este fenómeno se explica en parte por el
narcotráfico como ya sabéis en los años
80 la violencia de los narcos estaba
concentrada principalmente en colombia
en los tiempos de pablo escobar el
cártel de cali y las farc pero a partir
de los años 2000 colombia consiguió
sofocar la violencia como explicábamos
en vídeos anteriores el país de albín
sima luma sigue siendo uno de los
principales productores de cocaína del
mundo pero los distintos cárteles han
llegado a una especie de pax mafiosa es
decir que todas esas guerrillas se han
trasladado a centroamérica también hay
quien culpa de esto al cambio climático
según esta teoría el cambio climático
está ocasionando sequías en
centroamérica y si el campo no es
productivo la gente se muere de hambre y
tiene que marcharse
y por supuesto a todo esto hay que
sumarle las organizaciones de refugiados
por ejemplo pueblos sin fronteras es una
ong con sede en chicago que está
organizando caravanas migrantes lo que
llaman el vía crucis del migrante ellos
se encargan de ofrecer el apoyo
logístico para que miles de refugiados
puedan emprender su camino pero no sólo
hablamos de ongs sino también de mafias
que se dedican al tráfico de personas
sea cual sea la explicación lo cierto es
que hablamos de todo un éxodo
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en el año
2007 las patrullas fronterizas de
estados unidos capturaron a 16.000
guatemaltecos que cruzaban la frontera
ilegalmente 11 años más tarde en 2018 la
cifra sube a 115 mil guatemaltecos y os
preguntaréis son inmigrantes o
refugiados pues lo cierto es que en
honor a la verdad deberíamos hablar de
refugiados oficialmente se les sigue
considerando a migrantes pero seamos
honestos en la mayor parte de los casos
no hablamos de gente ambiciosa que
quiere probar suerte en el país de las
oportunidades en realidad son personas
que están escapando de la violencia
extrema muchos de ellos son niños y
mujeres que han sido amenazados por
alguna mara salvadoreña por ejemplo y
saben que les matarán si regresan eso
explica por qué están dispuestos a lo
que sea con tal de dejar su país y bien
digo lo que sea la ruta que va desde
guatemala hasta el paso en texas eeuu
tiene más de 3000 kilómetros pues bien
mucha gente lo hace andando otros lo
hacen a través del llamado tren de la
muerte y creo que ya os podéis imaginar
por qué lo llaman así
[Música]
y qué pasa cuando llegan a eeuu pues que
la mayoría de estos refugiados son
deportados pero ojo también hay algunos
afortunados que logran quedarse en los
últimos años las autoridades
estadounidenses han sacado varios
programas especiales para integrar a
toda esta gente solo en el año 2017 más
de 59 mil centroamericanos consiguieron
quedarse en el país os parecen muchos os
parecen pocos eso lo dejo a vuestra
opinión pero lo cierto es una cosa el
gobierno de méxico ha acogido a
muchísima menos gente para que os hagáis
una idea en este momento y más de 900
mil guatemaltecos viviendo en eeuu en
méxico son poco más de 50.000 y os
preguntaréis por qué porque los
centroamericanos no se quedan en mexico
que pasa que no les gusta méxico que
solamente quieren ir a eeuu pues lo
cierto es lo cierto es que ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
no es país para extranjeros en méxico lo
tiene muy claro no todos los inmigrantes
son iguales por ejemplo si estás viendo
este vídeo desde españa y eres blanco de
clase media tranquilo no hay ningún
problema méxico te recibe con los brazos
abiertos no vas a tener casi ningún
problema en conseguir el visado para que
os hagáis una idea méxico solo tiene
algo más de un millón de inmigrantes lo
que supone menos del 1 por ciento de la
población pues bien con estas cifras
mirad está grafo
[Música]
sí sí
como podéis ver de ese millón de
inmigrantes 900 mil son estadounidenses
27 mil vienen de españa y sólo 15 mil
vienen de honduras veréis hay más
franceses viviendo en mexico que
salvadoreños y esto es sorprendente si
tenemos en cuenta que el salvador está
muchísimo más cerca de mexico que
francia y que hablan el mismo idioma y
os preguntaréis por qué es esto es es
casualidad pues la respuesta es que no
mirad lo que decía la ley de inmigración
mexicana hasta hace unos pocos años
la secretaria de gobernacion podrá negar
a los extranjeros la entrada al país o
el cambio de calidad o característica
migratoria cuando lo exija el equilibrio
demográfico nacional habéis oído bien
eso del equilibrio demográfico nacional
es una forma muy bonita de decir
preferimos blancos y ricos y si vienes
de un país pobre casi que mejor no
vengas y es más cuando dice eso de que
te pueden cambiar el estatus migratorio
en cualquier momento lo que realmente
quieren decir es que en cualquier
momento te pueden deportar pero ya sé lo
que me vais a decir sobre todo los que
veáis este vídeo desde mexico es cierto
las cosas están cambiando de hecho en
octubre de 2018 el gobierno de méxico
lanzó este mensaje hoy méxico te
extiende la mano queremos que tú y todos
los migrantes se sientan tranquilos y
protegidos para apoyarte el gobierno de
méxico está lanzando el día de hoy el
plan estás en tu casa
estando en méxico podrás recibir
atención médica e incluso mandar a tus
hijos a la escuela también tendrás una
identificación oficial temporal para
hacer los trámites que necesites
mientras regularizar su situación
migratoria el señor que habéis visto en
la pantalla es enrique peña nieto- el ex
presidente de mexico una de sus últimas
medidas antes de dejar el gobierno fue
este plan llamado estás en tu casa el
sucesor de peña nieto
anb lo estaba encantado con este plan y
donald trump también estaba contento de
repente méxico daba un giro de 180
grados a su política migratoria y eso
significa que eeuu le podía pasar la
patata caliente a su vecino del sur pero
esperad un momento porque no todo es tan
bonito efectivamente el gobierno
mexicano primero con peña nieto y luego
con anv lo acogió a miles de refugiados
en sólo unos meses más de 10.000
guatemaltecos hondureños y salvadoreños
decidieron quedarse en el territorio
mexicano y os preguntaréis qué pensaban
los mexicanos al respecto pues nada
bueno
[Música]
el 58% de los mexicanos rechaza que se
permita entrar a migrantes efectivamente
trump no es el único que no quiere ver a
los refugiados ni en pintura a esto hay
que sumarle el hecho de que las
autoridades mexicanas no dan abasto con
tantísimos inmigrantes y refugiados
pensando bien alguien tiene que dar
todos esos certificados oficiales
construir albergues y ayudar a que los
centroamericanos se encuentren trabajo
todo esto cuesta dinero y compromiso
político y anv lo que juró su cargo en
diciembre de 2018 no quiere arriesgar
sus altísimos niveles de popularidad así
que con la policía y el ejército
desbordados y una sociedad totalmente en
contra de abrir las puertas a los
extranjeros el nuevo presidente no
quiere hacer experimentos
[Música]
méxico triplica las deportaciones de
migrantes centroamericanos con lópez
obrador el nuevo gobierno ha expulsado a
más de 45 mil personas en apenas 5 meses
casi 15.000 de ellas en abril y os
preguntaréis cuál es la consecuencia de
esta política migratoria por supuesto
los mayores damnificados son los cientos
de miles de centroamericanos que ya no
pueden quedarse ni en méxico ni tampoco
en eeuu pero esta no es la única
consecuencia pensando bien por un
momento si amlo no quiere acoger a los
refugiados a donde creéis que se van
pues exacto continúan su ruta hacia la
frontera estadounidenses en otras
palabras que de nuevo la patata caliente
vuelve a manos de donald trump estamos
ya en mayo del año 2019 y es en este
momento cuando la casablanca amenaza a
méxico con aranceles del 5 por ciento
sus exportaciones en otras palabras que
amlo se ve entre la espada y la pared si
acoge a todos los inmigrantes tiene un
problema enorme tanto económico como de
popularidad pero
si no los acoge tiene un problema
igualmente enorme con eeuu en esta
tesitura cual diría es que es la única
solución posible
pues está
[Música]
el programa estadounidense quédense en
mexico se expande dejando más gente en
una peligrosa ciudad mexicana en otras
palabras que en mayo de 2019 donald
trump se acercó a nuestro amigo amlo y
le dijo a ver méxico chavalote mira me
da igual como lo consigas me da igual
haz lo que te dé la gana con los
refugiados con los inmigrantes con los
centroamericanos como los quieras llamar
que te los quieres quedar de los que das
que los quieres mandar a canadá pues los
mandas a canadá a groenlandia a francia
o wal mart y me da igual te los metes
por el ahora bien
como veía a un inmigrante de estos
cruzar mi frontera mi querido amigo
méxico te vas te vas acá porque te voy a
meter unos aranceles unos aranceles así
así de grandes te lo voy a meter y no te
voy a decir por dónde y cuál es la
solución más rápida para amlo pues si no
puede llevar a los inmigrantes al cielo
ni tampoco al infierno los deja en el
purgatorio concretamente méxico ha
desplegado a más de 6 mil soldados de la
guardia nacional
para contener a todos esos
centroamericanos en una especie de
guetos en ciudades fronterizas
[Música]
es decir que no les deporta pero tampoco
les deja avanzar ni muchísimo menos
integrarse en la sociedad mexicana por
ejemplo en los últimos meses miles de
personas están concentradas en ciudades
como nuevo laredo en la frontera norte
en condiciones infrahumanas no hay
médicos a duras penas hay comida y la
criminalidad está creciendo a ritmos
acelerados pero sin duda alguna la
ciudad que más problemas tiene es
tapachula en el estado de chiapas
tapachula es la primera ciudad mexicana
nada más cruzar la frontera con
guatemala pues bien en esta ciudad se
han registrado entre 20.000 y 30.000
solicitudes de asilo el ejército
mexicano está en la frontera ahora mismo
conteniendo a los flujos de migrantes y
ya se han registrado asesinatos por
parte de maras salvadoreñas y toda clase
de bandas violentas de centroamérica en
otras palabras que todos esos refugiados
han terminado en exactamente la misma
situación de la que estaban escapados
es cierto que donald trump no les quiere
pero seamos honestos y sé que esto va a
molestar a muchos de los que nos
escuchas en méxico amlo tampoco les
quiere
mientras ambos países se pasan la patata
caliente miles de personas están
viviendo un auténtico infierno
[Música]
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros como creéis que se puede
solucionar este problema creéis que
méxico podría hacer algo algo para
acoger a todos estos refugiados creéis
que eeuu debería dar ayudas económicas a
mexico para que pudieran hacer frente a
todos estos migrantes o tal vez deberían
llegar a un acuerdo para compartir
responsabilidades podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios
pero antes dejadme que se hable un
momento de las leyendas lines es una
herramienta de seguridad todo-en-uno que
incluye un vpn para tus dispositivos de
tal forma que puedas usar redes públicas
de manera segura y anónima
seguro que a ti al igual que a mí
también te preocupa tu privacidad en la
red pues bien con tasas le mantendrá su
identidad online segura das link te
protegerá de todo tipo de amenazas
contra tu identidad ya sabes que hay
muchísimos hackers ahí fuera pensando en
cómo aprovecharse de ti y la mejor forma
de esquivar los es utilizando las ley
también hacen una cosa muy interesante
que se llama monitoreo de la tarde web
que consiste en escanear la web en busca
de datos personales filtrados o robados
alertando te al instante en caso de que
tus datos personales se encuentren donde
no deben
de esta forma puedes tomar medidas
rápidamente y por supuesto das lane te
ayudará a generar contraseñas seguras y
cada vez que la web
turno te pida introducirlas te ayudará a
rellenar los campos requeridos de forma
rápida y sencilla es súper cómodo se
acabó eso de no acordar te de las
contraseñas como os decía antes das line
es totalmente gratuita pero hay algunas
opciones premium en caso de que quieras
disponer de más servicios entras en das
line puntocom barra visual polítiques y
utilizando el código visual polítiques
tendrás una prueba de estas opciones
premium totalmente gratis durante 30
días si después decides continuar con
ellas podrás obtener un descuento del
10% a la hora de contratar las
hazme caso y entra en el link que te
dejamos en la descripción para descargar
te das line de forma gratuita no te
arrepentirás
un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]